one thing that i always like
ask myself is how much have i learned in
the past year
and how much am i going to learn in the
next year and for me that is the main
question uh so each time asking myself
that
but at the same time
i think that patience is underrated
these days
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hello at stanford leap birthright xl
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
hello and welcome to 20-minute leaders
today i am joined with ahu dialin mo
senior vice president at visita the
leading business management app for smbs
ehu joined visita as the first employee
a long journey from the first line of
code to serving hundreds of thousands of
businesses
after seven years as visitors vp r d
edward led the acquisition of ystamp and
its merger into visita since then under
ahud's management ystamp one of the
leading email signature solutions has
rapidly accelerated its growth with over
10 years of experience in startups
edward's passion lies in the
intersection of tech business and
management especially in the sas world
iowa holds an mba from the calgary
konati joint program at bsc in computer
science and is a graduate of 8200
you know obviously looking at your and
your path and looking at the things that
you've done it's quite non-traditional
in today's world i think they say that
the average person spends roughly
1.5 to 3 years at a company and that's
that's pretty being pretty generous and
and you've pretty much quadrupled that
assumption uh which which says a lot
about about about you and it says a lot
about about the company that you're with
and so i'm excited to unravel a little
bit with you
what it means for somebody to navigate a
company like vicita the way that you
have from a you know tech lead vpr d
chief revenue officer senior vice
president of of you know of a company
that you are now that you've acquired so
a lot to unpack and uh thank you very
much for being here
thank you very much so yeah i think uh
you you touched uh an interesting point
um but to be honest uh besides that i
didn't think it would be 11 years uh
in some to some extent it was
uh one half years in each company
because each stage the company is
different so
i think that's
part of it uh part of it is visita and
uh great people are very very fun um but
part of it is growing and changing with
the company
fantastic so tell me just a little bit
about vicita as a company i'm you know
high level what what what are you all
are doing and then i would love to
understand internally this these
transitions from tech lead vpr d chief
revenue officer and senior vice
president
yeah so we still started actually as a
scheduling uh or or to be honest we
started
when blogging was still very common
as a way for bloggers to get more
revenue and then we got to scheduling
and like many companies that start um at
a niche and then they grow to a platform
so that's what happened to visitor
so we found our customers
being small business owners
micro
micro businesses especially service
providers and then we grew to a platform
that provide
payment collection
uh scheduling obviously crm uh
everything together
uh and it has been quite a journey uh
starting from from from that um
well the
you know so so vicita
we understand and then you know when
you're joining take me back to when
you're joining vc10 you're saying that
you know you feel like you've worked
a year and a half two years at four
different companies and not just one
company
what does that actually mean internally
because at the end you are working for
the same company or probably working
with the same people
how did it how did these transitions
create
the sense that you're working for four
different companies
yeah so we started off uh at an office
with two actually sublisting an office
with two rooms i think that was probably
the the most fun part um
of it i was working before that in
cantor and
i joined kaltura after the army service
and i thought like kaltura was back then
a hundred people or so and i thought i
could influence
but pretty quickly i understood that uh
already a startup with a hundred
employees and now i get it uh in this
year as well it's really hard to make an
impact i was at the beginning of the
journey of my journey and i thought it's
time to take the risk and i found it
clevy through a mutual friend uh so the
beginning was really exciting uh you
don't know where you're going you're
starting your your
shooting arrows um
so so i think that's that's how we
started and then each time like actually
when you move a place and more people
join uh and the core of the the people
join so i think that is the transition
the people you work with um and it's
like different companies in that sense
like you work with different people
and those those people are your
day-to-day the people you work with and
interact uh
mostly i'm and still you know and we
can't hide the fact that in the last few
years you know the
terms like the great resignation and and
essentially this idea of of you know
independence and um
and disconnection from perhaps one
entity and saying you know we can
potentially work we can potentially have
a few families we can work with a few
places
and still during this time you're saying
you know actually i'm okay and and and
i've been okay for a while and i don't
need to to to do these things what what
what what sort of the decision that goes
to everyone because obviously you're
thinking about it obviously you have
opportunities and people are approaching
like crazy yet you still make a decision
i think that's a good question and and
one thing that i always like
ask myself is how much have i learned in
the past year uh and how much am i going
to learn in the next year and for me
that is the main question uh so each
time asking myself that
but at the same time
i think that patience is underrated
these days because we had different
periods in visita
highs and lows
and if you have patience i think that uh
that you get a lot out of it uh uh at
the end of it
sometimes you need to make bet like
tough decisions but many times people
like let's say quit or change too early
and if they had the patience they they
would capitalize on on that
interesting okay and
now going back a little bit to to your
most recent transition to being senior
vice president why stump with vesita
back to the acquisition
the what was different about this
situation strategically or something or
or something that was non-trivial and
you've experienced this obviously from
well before
you know the acquisition you've known
vicita and so you've been a part of this
team and the strategy here
so i so i've been to vista for seven
years uh when etsy came to me that there
is an opportunity to acquire ystam i was
i just finished my mba at kellogg so i
moved more to the business part um and
he asked me to do the due diligence
there so it was really interesting
usually or in the acquired side uh
people do the due diligence
due diligence um
for you so it was really interesting to
meet a team uh the team wasn't that big
like it was 15 people um in total
including like freelancers
and the main idea there was to um create
synergy towards lead generation so why
stem does
email signature generator and manager uh
which is quite surprising to be honest
you don't you you wouldn't guess that
there is a like interesting business and
there is out of it
um but if you look at hubspot and any
book as well they use it as legion uh so
we see that thought uh we can take that
and cross sell to visita from that
traffic
uh and
we we made acquisition it took some time
uh you know acquisition don't go
uh
usually don't take a month or two it
takes a bit more than that
uh and after acquiring acquiring y stamp
uh beside getting some synergy we
actually found out the potential of why
some as a business is much bigger than
we thought um
and since then we have really
accelerated we're now 50 people within
visita uh also some synergy with visita
but growing the business as itself at
itself and going up market as well uh
with why stem that which has been like
the the most significant change of
transformative change revise them
incredible so in a second i want to hear
a little bit about your
your experience
you know leading this cohort but before
that going back to the due diligence
phase of company mentioning something
it's very very true most people
are on the diligence side they they have
they get the research done on them and
you are the one that's challenged with
asking the right questions and diving
deep into them you know besides the
trivial things you know the numbers and
the trajectories and making sure that
everything's clean and by the books
you know you're sitting there and you're
thinking okay like what do i need to
know what are what are really the things
that we are not checking here are there
some non-trivial things that you've
figured out along the process that are
that are really relevant to a process
like this
um that that's a good question
not sure i reflected on that um
when i started uh the process uh i
created a document like documenting the
process and um
trying to
like put a recommendation on writing i
think many people don't we don't usually
don't do that at companies especially
startups like we work more like
a bit of a hustle um
so i think to me it was like creating
the thesis of um of can it work and um
it's a soft thing i think one of one of
the most significant part was actually
the people that we met people uh and we
see we saw sincerity uh and the
potential
there were like similarities in culture
i think that's one part that it's it's
hard to um to nail it and understand
because you meet right now the people
but um we felt there is like some
similarities between visiting and and
why some so that's one part obviously
and and by the way how do you gauge that
i mean how do you it's you can't just
give it a score and say okay your
culture is x our culture is why
therefore we have synergy how do you go
and test whether a company like vicita
has a culture with a startup that's 15
people
yeah i think i think y stamp was
actually uh um founded around the same
year of visita
so i think uh looking at why somebody
decided and weissen was bootstrapped
mostly bootstrapped so basilica is busy
backed uh and why stamp is uh his
bootstrap got really
funding but
they were kind of moving in parallel
and going into
it goes to looking at the office
actually going the office and the
feeling there um so
to be honest hard to say uh it's a
feeling uh that it can work um and also
just like the feeling we get with people
uh that you see that uh the connection
is there
amazing well obviously you know there's
it also says something interesting when
when you're you the company's being
acquired and then you're mentioning that
it was acquired for several reasons but
but there was one surprising element
here which is actually the business
itself otherwise temp is you know has
much more potential but this also
requires that in order to harness that
potential you know you need the people
to want to continue building it and feel
that they still have you know a stake in
in ystamp what was that experience like
growing the business
while the company is now a a child
company of another one
so the first my first uh at the
beginning my first uh job was making
people feel comfortable
and actually the people of wise them got
like me accepted really well so i felt
really comfortable with the with a
leading team in y stamp um and we
started working on synergies with visita
um
and i started actually learning like you
i like to join a new company so you
asked about like the career so for me i
joined a new company at that point
and
at the beginning you try um to learn and
say less
i think until you understand the
business
and quite quickly
uh
we saw that they are under investing in
marketing um the product uh there's a
lot to do in the in the product so we
started doing things there
we started investing in going up markets
or in larger companies
so we saw like all these
opportunities uh
presented in front of us and uh and just
like together the conviction grew
together uh with the team and as it as
we went on like conviction grew
uh and now we actually
uh signed the first fortune 500 company
for ysam so uh yeah going upper market
is a is a long challenge like it's a
it's a long journey
selling to these kind of companies
right and so joining leadership of a
team you know that you're previously
visita and you're still visited but now
you're mainly y stamp and you're
mentioning that they sort of accepted
you into
in into the culture that they've built
there
is that were there were other things
that you that you did you know
intentionally to make it um to make it a
bigger success was it luck that your
cultures are fitting and that they like
you and you like them
in other words are were there was there
intentional strategy into
figuring out okay how can i make this
process as smooth as possible for
everybody to increase the chances so i
think like everything in life there is
part of it is part of it is just just
luck
i didn't know i think the team
didn't know that it go will go that way
uh most of the team stayed
and i know i
know now that some of them said okay
i'll stick in for a year and then i'll
see and now we're already two and a half
years after
um
so i think it's it's about creating
those connections and learning the
business and and creating success
together so the more success we've
created um the more we felt that that
were working together
um
but i think uh i think
it's like visita is is a bigger company
and we have the infrastructure and the
hr and finance and everything uh all
everything we need uh going working
really well
um but at the same time we have like the
luxury of being a smaller smaller
organization within visita so uh so we
have this like feeling of togetherness
um
so i think it's a lot it's a lot about
it it's mostly about the people and
working together and having fun together
that's to be honest i know it's a cliche
but uh but that's that that that's the
truth
very very cool and so i would if you're
looking now you know your day to day and
and looking at these 12 years and what
perhaps you've learned about yourself
you know as both as a leader but also as
you know a a member of of a group and it
sounds like you are very very much
embodied this idea of a team player and
that you really enjoy being part of a
team i mean it really it really
resonates through the things that you're
saying
what did you learn about yourself
in these 12 years a lot i think i i i
wasn't a dad when i joined vc i wasn't
married so obviously those are very
significant years
um
and
i think i i learned to trust my
instincts
like my
i think it takes some time uh to
understand um that what you're thinking
and your instincts um are are
taking you to the right place
um
and i think that's one thing um
i mean there's a lot of things in terms
of management working with people i mean
recruiting people you get to so many
different
uh so many different situations um in
our people that signed and then um say
no and then the other way around so
within every aspect in terms of being
more
um
patience with other people and listening
more um it takes also time to get that
it's not the most important it's not
it's important to listen uh and and be
more like calm uh even when you are
when you have this intensity intensity
so i think it's really
it's been a very long journey like you
said uh and i think that every part like
in some sense i feel that i'm the semper
like i think it's everything in life
like in some sense i feel that i'm the
same person but in in other in some
sense sense like everything changed so
it's it's like keeping the core and
changing like and learning and changing
at the same time so uh um
if if that makes sense
a hundred percent keeping the core but
continuing to change to improve to learn
to grow
and uh and i'm tying it back to
the very first thing that we talked
about which is this idea of patience
and
saying things through and then you know
saying okay you know the
let's let's
breathe for a second and perhaps we'll
enjoy staying here maybe we'll want to
stay here for for many years maybe if we
have patience we can get along better
with the people around us
maybe we can even
take part in the acquisition of a
company and then become a leader within
that organization and get accepted as a
leader which is something
very very nontrivial thing i believe the
statistic is that the vast majority of
acquisitions fail because of the because
the integration
fails and you know a lot of people are
talking about the fact that the
technology technological integration
fails but really it's about people right
i mean we will overcome technological
barriers now and you know it's about
people looking at like being at a place
for 11 years and obviously you want to
create success so there's a quote i love
uh from i really love from nepal
saying
desire is in agreement with you with
your with yourself not to be happy until
you get what you want
so i think it's always like you always
have the desire to get somewhere but at
the same times you need to keep yourself
to remind yourself to enjoy the the the
way there so it's always that like
trying to
to navigate both them or both of them
like being competitive and
wanting to get to something and like
always looking like we're all
competitive and we want to
grow and do more
but at the same time
um like i said the the
my best time at visitor was probably
until we were like 30 people it was the
most fun so you need to have to remember
that and enjoy enjoy while while you're
at it
oh thank you very very much this was
awesome this was really really fun and
and interesting and i wish you best of
luck in in everything that you're going
to do and i'm excited to to see what
teams yeah you're a part of and in it it
was very very interesting for me to hear
in the way that you think and and
everything about patience and teamwork
and culture and uh thank you very much
best of luck with wise stamp and we
thank god
i've listened to a couple of uh episodes
now uh on the way to work and uh
looking at how many
episodes you already done the
consistency there so talking about
consistency uh it's amazing to see um i
think people and appreciate what it
takes so
really really appreciate your work
i appreciate it thank you very much
[Music]